thank you for joining today's session
um QR code where if you scan so just
basically take you to the GitHub repo
um so
this is the GitHub video sorry it's a
bit small
um okay so I think there's a paper
called search engine Workshop
and when you go to it like your hub if
you click on that you'll be taken to the
environment and that's all the
dependencies installed for every session
so if you missed this
um
foreign
s and some things you want to consider
for production use cases
so Robbie and I are machine learning
engineers
at Walmart search
reach out to us later
so
what is the history of like building a
service system
um I would say like in the last several
years there have been about four maybe
Milestones actually so the first thing
is regular employees it's a very simple
system
and we'll see how it how simple it is
the next system is like you know instead
of just using simple tokens can we try
to build a simple language model that
considers
a person that documents how
how often the term occurs across the
Corpus things like standing upwards so
that took a lot of time in the research
community and then in 2000s once we
started getting like large web traffic
uh
there was a lot of breaches that were
spent on things like learning to rank uh
we started seeing like in 2012 things
like word to bet
and then you know in the late let's say
like 2014 2015 with the start of like
things like but they started seeing like
back to base retriever so those are how
I would kind of improve the four
four errors to the timeline so let's
start with
open base retrieval
so let's say you know you have a query
like pictures
so the first thing we might do is you
might tokenize it you might tokenize it
by white space so we have four tokens
here but then maybe you might know stop
words so words that occur pretty
commonly so in this case making off
might be removed the other thing you
might do is you might scan the tokens so
like it's a plane you might just play so
now you have three tokens so now you
look at your purpose and you try to see
like which of these documents have uh
most of the books so if you look at the
first one images of cat plane uh it
doesn't have the word picture but it has
images but because we're using like a
pure token or a word based approach uh
we don't really match the intent there
um if you take a look at the last
document the document is pretty long it
has a bunch of words there
um it technically has all the words that
we're looking for but
um it doesn't really seem to match the
intent
um but based on this approach if you're
just answering I mean the tokens match
documentary would be considered relevant
but I would argue that maybe document
one and document 2 is probably the most
relevant
God
so
then we started looking into doing
something it's a little bit smarter so
here's a nice
uh flashcard from Chris Alvin then this
is basically term frequency and idea so
basically instead of just answering if a
word just occurs maybe consider it if
the word is a common word if the word is
common in the Corpus so this is just two
ideas that are combined together and
insert this Boolean score we have this
a combined score
and that's one small problem with this
you see that we are just I'm saying
don't forget to see an idea if there's
no like scale factor or dampening Factor
so again this is you know the story
detail of em25 which Powers
a lot of databases like elastic search
and solar the formula looks a little bit
scary but if you notice that here we
have like the idfps which we saw
previously but we have some extra
adapting actors we have the term
frequency but then we have like some
dampening factors concerning that the
length of the document
if you also see here like
um
here the original term frequency will
just continuously contribute but
um in this formula you kind of adapt and
adapt it like let's say 20 tokens
so there's a lot happening in this
formula but I just wanted to show that
uh this is uh this is a model that is
used in like databases like
elasticsearch
uh domestic search is a open source
search engine it housed a lot of
companies search tax
um not only does it support like
bootstrip boosting it supports things
like filtering automatically it builds
like a distributed
um solar system
and so just some slides on the last
episode you know assuming you have like
a corpus
for like an e-commerce item s like an
idle description brand
um this is how you might match between
last user schema where you can say
fields of text that is something it's a
keyboard but there's something to be
married so you can index kind of the
complex document
and you know if you have a query like
Nike shoes under hundreds not only can
you do like this Boolean retrieval
um so here I've been searching for a
query the tokens Nike issues under 100
if you're looking in the title in the
description if it appears in the title
you're boosting it by a factor too we
are filtering with the brand new tennis
match uh we are filtering the price is
less than
100 so you can build a very powerful
retrieval system with something like
elasticsearch
yeah
and you know
um in the production system if you have
like hundreds of millions of documents
elasticsearch allows you to basically
shot the focus
um so instead of starting with one large
instance you're basically uh
Stars putting your search across
multiple clusters multiple nodes kind of
customers
so that was token based retrieval
um and then the next era uh and there's
a lot of work that happened here in
learning to rank so let's say you have
your query of address and on the left
hand side
you retrieve these three items you all
have rent somewhere but the most
relevant item is probably the last item
so it didn't come in the right order
that you probably expected so what you
do is you feed it into a ranking model
like HD boost or live TVM and what you
consider this time is like features
inside your query you know like maybe uh
extend the product type because the
product type match the item does the
color match the
item and the query things you might
consider from the item level is like is
the price like a reasonably priced item
uh is is there a lot of customer reviews
for this item and other things you can
consider in the context is like what are
other ways that the user has searched in
the past so you can build up and
consider all these features and then
kind of re-rank it and get your final
ordering
so I would say in production most
companies can use like vm35 approach
plus the learning to run and build a
pretty powerful system
but there's still one issue with like
like talking based approach that we
looked at
it will not solve like if there's a
lexical Gap right so covid coronavirus
only can't they all can be the same
thing but with just a token-based thing
for Kobe it's not going to really match
Corona lives
um the token based approach approach
will not solve like
ambiguity so depending on your purpose
the same work and the different things
in a difference in a different context
and pure bad word token based approach
doesn't consider position like River
Bank versus Bank River it means
different things and like oh sorry the
bank river is you will never see that in
a normal English sentence
and definitely
in the last example like she will pop
the car so they can walk in the park we
have the same token appearing in the
same sentence with meaning different
things
so
um that's all I wanted to talk about on
a token based retrieval let's kind of
take a look at the first lab so if it's
easier there's a Jupiter Hub environment
hub.np.training
um if you want also the repo there's a
50 link for that or you can scan it
through our code
um just making sure that was everyone
able to
get the environments on the book with
any issues
the environment is just basically having
this repo call so
um all the notebooks that we're going to
cover are inside this section here and
also um this slide that we're covering
are available here if you want to uh
Concepts later
so let's take a look at the notebooks
that we have today
so the first notebook that I would like
to take a look at
is
um oh right I didn't mention the data
set that we're going to be using today
so
um there is a company on Splash that has
provided about 25
000 images and like captions so
um you have like the photo ID and photo
URL and you have a description what
we're doing in five building today is
you know given a query can we build a
search system that the streams relevant
items
so it is about 25
000 images here so let's take a look at
the first notebook you know zero one
em25 elastic
um let me just duplicate it now feel
free to run this or you know look at our
rendered output
okay um the name set is already ignored
in this environment so you don't need to
do anything uh
oh uh I think like for this session like
if you could just visit the computer Hub
environment um
but um I can help set up
um
thank you for this one yes I I wanted to
make this kind of like practical so
there's a lot of dependencies and
so so just
um yeah it might be easier today
um
training and just authenticate with your
GitHub
so let me just clear the output here
hopefully it is
um
so you know just the fast Imports I have
a hug and face data set rendered
this data set so what are the columns
that we have so we have like photo ID
photo URL caption will maybe be looking
at the photo URL and how so you know
this is what a sample record would look
like
um you know here is the
description that we're going to be using
um so for this image there's the
description woman exploring in the
forest
um as part of this environment is
already in plastic search cluster
already set up so
um
it's just localhost and Report
um briefly we're going to talk about
tokenizers and like
um so we saw that example about how
elastics set out the
uh the plain example how some of the
tokens were extend so let's just look at
Classics website before you start to
deny this you know I mean we have plenty
of time so you can actually get
something questions oh yeah
apologies but at um yes I moved a little
bit faster uh this is the first section
about like token based retrieval
um yeah so you know the if there are any
questions about the previous sections or
as we go into this notebook please feel
free to bring it up
[Music]
um
so
um you know elasticsearch is like a
production-based systems it has some
like default options for how do you
tokenize how do you stand so if you have
a query like you know
an HTML tag you know elasticsearch is
built on this thing so you have let's
say HTML tags here
um they have some built-in tokenizers
you know if you think the same thing
like you just wanted to organize some
white space
or if you want to use the default
tokenizer so one thing if you notice the
white space tokenizer it doesn't really
deal with like these HTML tags properly
uh the standard look nicer parses them
correctly
um
so one thing I want to so their
tokenizes and analyzes but don't spend
too much time here but one of the
analysis is in stock quiz so if you see
here like original query has like
elastic searches built on top of the
stop words you know is on it just gets
removed
most of the time they don't really add
much value in your query
yes yes
is there any uh so
what type of organizers
yeah so
um it's a elasticsearch has some
built-in options so like it says the
engram tokenizers for character based uh
there's a standard page to apply so we
have classics there's custom default
options
um and you can of course Define your own
tokenizes it also has 12 prices for
different languages
so it is pretty powerful for your
standard use case
yes
[Music]
yeah like um so an mlpk and like uh
spacing has some good options there
um I think like
for the English language like um the I
think the standard things like
um
I was breaking on white space
kind of dealing with HTML tags like the
pink in this case it will it should be
comparable but obviously like Stacy and
uh I don't think he have like much more
richer models
um
yeah so um
we're just gonna in this notebook let's
just use the default tokenizer
um uh and just let's try to see what
results we get
so I have this helpful method using the
icon elastic search client
um I'm creating an index with it being
that's passed I'm telling elasticsearch
to create
three Sharps so it's not 25 000
documents will be split into thirds
and then if I give a data stream of
documents I'm just going to iterate
across it and just kind of clean up some
things like create a document ID remove
any empty or now Fields
um
and once I have my elastic search index
created I just call client.surgeon I
tell it I want to search for the field I
want to search in multiple Fields but in
our case we need to be searching in the
description field
and how many results were there any
elasticsearch will do that dm25 formula
that we saw before
um
so I created my index here
um you can see some settings that
elastic search
exposes so this is the index name I
created this is a number of shots that I
created
um there's one replica three shots
uh and we have about 25k office
um
the inserting step
yes in inserting staff we started 25k
documents incident about uh close to 3
000 documents per second that's a pretty
amazing I mean that's a pretty good uh
insertion rate variant elastic such as
extending Brokenness and doing all this
processing and updating the indexes so
it's pretty fast
and you know since we have three shots
we see Shard one has about seven
thousand five documents on the second
shot is about seven thousand two other
documents and it's about nine legs per
shot
um yeah so let's see how well the result
is actually performing so
um
in elastic stage you know you can became
a document by the ID
um if you need that but in our case
we're going to be retrieving
we're going to kind of do a print-based
treatment
so let's take between two dogs playing
in the snow
let's see what results are returned
um so this is like the raw elastic
search payload giving you metadata apart
from each other
how many how many items could be in a
possible recall
um it has this Source field that if you
want all the metadata that was inserted
for a document
um
let's see and you know there's a score
how relevant this document is for us
um for your brain
um let's see
um and you know elasticsearch is built
on that bm35 formula so
you can easily tell it like hey if I if
I tell explain equals true you can see
why a certain score was given for a
document so if we consider this first
document
um that
um I think it was like two dogs playing
so the title the description for this
first document was two white dogs
um and we see that in the details
um it tells you
I'm giving this uh
um a boosting score of 2.2 because
there's the po2 inside
um inside inside this document I'm
giving
um score of dogs I mean for the token
dogs I'm giving it a score of a boost of
2.2 the IDF value that we saw is six
um you know how many how many documents
contain this term nine
um here so it gives you all these
brain debugging information so it is an
explainable kind of model
um yeah so the score is
um
yeah so but
um let's just look at the results that I
returned
um
yeah so
so this is the results that I've done
for two dogs playing this you know
um you know why did this come yeah and
so the in this document we're looking at
the description and Order that's
provided so
um they're not really feature-rich
um so you know this one is two white
dogs it's not for me that this doesn't
really look like the best image but I
can see that okay two dogs I don't see
plane noise anywhere here
um this one two baby elephants okay
they're playing but it's not dogs so you
see that just based on pure like broken
based things
um
you could see like some slightly
irrelevant results too you can boost
some elastic search very options like
you know matching faces tokens and
action
uh that appear together but there's
still some gaps here let's just quickly
look at some examples before we switch
to the next
thing so you know employ and go on beach
um you know we see blue we see Beach but
this again maybe not the best image but
again based on the description as to I
did and just one last image and this
thing here
if you look at you know kind of a little
bit meta query that someone has
shared you know like at the end of the
tunnel
um like this is at the end of the tunnel
but it's not really tracking that
context so
the entrance price is a very strong
Baseline
um we saw how quickly it gets to insert
you know it takes four milliseconds to
retrieve a result on a very small you
know a single note so it is a pretty
strong Baseline in fact let's look at
kind of some Modern approaches
um
yeah to kind of solve this problem
yeah and this action the embedding based
retail is a little bit dense so you know
face uh feel free to ask me questions
that might be there
um again the slides are available in the
assets uh if you want to you know follow
along or just look ahead or look at it
later
um
so
so what do we want with them that you
know embeddings is just a way to
represent the word or a concept
um in the vector so what we ideally want
is you know words that mean the same
thing like card automobile to basically
have the same representation we want
documents that talk about the same thing
like ice cream is great or
or an ice cream is the best regardless
of you know length of the document we
want them to basically have the same
representation
um what was the first approach to kind
of build this kind of word or concept
based
um embeddings you know work to back it
was released in 2013 the idea was to
look at the sequence the sequence of
words
um and then given a given a word you
look at the context to the left effect
to the right of it and then you try to
build this very simple Network that
tries to learn the ways to predict
um this is one of the
one of the models over direct it was in
and people have extended this
work-to-back idea for sequences
from Instagram that they shared in 2019
where basically if you look at
um accounts of the images that people
have looked at we can try to learn uh
embedding for the accounts
um
yeah so see um inverted back the
previous thing we're learning like word
similarity here they're learning
accounts to learning
um you can also expand this to other
things so GrubHub
um expanded is to like restaurants so
they look at all the restaurants that
people have interacted in the session
and then they try to look at try to
create like a restaurant-based embedding
and those this was actually a talk that
was done in 2019 in high data you can
watch the recording if you're interested
so
is a pretty powerful approach especially
if you have contraction with either in
text or like a sequence that from your
launcher
um but these days you know especially
for NLP or just tax people use food
right
um you know giving you giving an input
you know
um but has a tokenizer it might be a bit
small here but if you look like plane
you know uh there it gets upgraded into
like
sub words right there's a play and then
the pound and ing so this is some good
token I said and
um where it just build on top of and uh
as part of your training and as part of
your implicator model so it has like
position and Medics that you feed into
your model so
um yeah but it's really powerful so you
don't want to talk too much in the
details of it but just wanted to show
that what I'm answer this position
um so if you want to learn context a
little bit better
um and you know but
um the base model of hood supports up to
like 512 tokens and it has 12 encoded
layers and after each encoder there's an
embedding that is available and you know
you can use those embeddings
um but gives a word based synthetic
um so you can kind of pull all the
embeddings together and kind of get a
sentence of it
and this is one good approach
um
yes and bird solves many of the problems
that we have kind of seen with like kind
of just open page things like it learns
contextualized embedding
um it captures position so it has a good
idea of language and just staying on a
very large Focus
um but one of the problems with using
just bullet acids for like building a
retrieval system is good by itself
doesn't really capture similarity really
well
so we need to have a model that kind of
makes our model learn similarly better
so how do you solve this one the aism
that would call a cross disorder
basically the idea is you feed both
let's say sentence one and sentence two
you feed it into third word uses its
like a tension mechanism and it outputs
a score whether these two items are
similar or not
um this model gives very good results
but
um for a search system
um if you use a spray like this to
compare
uh with the entire purpose it's not
really efficient for information
retrieval purposes
so approach that many people use
is this two camera model
so the idea is you know you have your
sentence one sentence two you feed it to
your encoder in this case it's good very
cool and bad things uh while the model
is there while it's being trained you're
telling your model to kind of learn if
sentence one and sentence two is similar
so this is the training passive that
you're giving for your model
um
you can use the same work model here or
you can use different encoders depending
on your domain but um for this use case
it might make sense to use the same
encoder so if you have a lot of data
where you have
like um two pairs and you have a score
you can learn you can use this to kind
of learn similarity
um you know cinematic based academic
um maybe I'll take a pause here uh
any personal stuff
um going all the way from a simple
um work to that kind of embedding to
kind of go into the sentence piece of a
model that kind of does similarities
so what about an item which has a name
which is which is
so how does
uh yeah so um so I guess here like if
the
um if like if the item
tokens are not in the purpose I give
hopefully like the soundboard to
organization would solve some of it but
definitely if the tokens are not in your
process like you might need to use you
might need to clean the documents
yes
um can't you
expand the query based on the synonyms
between words and you get the synonyms
from something like word to back
yeah so that's a
um that's a good point about like
synonyms so even in the previous
approach
um with pm35 like we can probably get
the results by using synonyms here
um
here a bit like go to bed you know if
you train it you can enhance the grade
that the user has typed to kind of use
to use the synonyms to kind of retrieve
relevant results
um we're making one of the nice things
about like
um training a model that is uh like this
this where you have two similar Concepts
and you don't explicitly Define
um like the central symmetics should
of course
um
yeah so
um this we have a small lab and just
play with some of the results that we
saw that
um yeah compare it against the BMW find
codes by using uh pre-trained uh model
that is trained with the sentence
similarity task
so if you take a look at notebook
um yeah so there's the notebook here
called density fiber notice so millbus
is like a vector database we'll talk
about it a little bit later but
um let me just close all the workbooks
and to keep this notebook
so there's a nice Library called
sentence transform I'm just going to
click run off this just take some time
so this is a nice python package called
settings Transformer and in the
uh in the oven piece oh they've uploaded
several models that were trained on this
um this buy input architecture that we
saw so this purpose was actually this
model was actually trained on one
billion certain squares taken from
a wide amount of wide variety of data so
Reddit Commons Wikipedia answers uh and
a small group of Staff each team so it
has it's trained on a very large Core
Business and in similarity you know
titles titles abstract uh duplicate
questions so it has a good it should
have a good understanding of like
similarity
um
yeah so let's just you know use this
existing model as this
so this model you know given a sentence
it would give you a 384 dimensional
vector
um
yeah so
um I know this is the python client to
talk to this Vector database that we
will be storing
um so if I import this model in sentence
Transformer you know you see the
Transformer
um and then you have this cooling layer
that basically dates the intermediate
embeddings and then returns a 3D for
dimensional Factor
um so this is like a stack of a question
here
um we see that once when you give it to
the model like it it does do
tokenization
uh it has like this attention masks some
some of these things from work you see
you have like the Intermediate token
embeddings and then you have the final
sentence
in our case we're just going to be
looking at the sentence embedding
which is trained for dimensions
okay so
um it's token embeddings um in that
Creative Study tokens
so hugging face has this nice Library
Auto tokenizer so you can kind of see
the interior results yeah
um and
um kind of the subword organization that
we talked about
um doesn't just you know use the token
so creative and white space
so
um in this case since we're just looking
at the results I will directly go to
that
um
let's see
so you know this again is like an open
source Vector database so here's just
some examples of using the client so you
make the collection
exists we can drop it
um
we need to provide I'm sorry what is it
he is going let me just go here so
so one thing is compared to like the
pn25 approach like embedding generating
and embedding for like 35 000 documents
like on this instance that we have
will take about three to four minutes so
25 000 is pretty small uh this is not
using a GPU so that's why it does take
some time
um but let me just go yeah so this is
how you know uh we always specific so no
lists again it's a vector database it
stores its metadata in MySQL when you
create a collection or a document you
need to Define you know the field types
Plastics are just a little bit smart
about kind of inferring these sites
automatically but from these Vector
databases uh you do need to specify the
schema beforehand
um specifically you need to specify like
I need to identify a vector and even
discuss five embedding and size
those kind of stuff okay
um
so
um I mainly I want to show the
receivable results so let's look at the
for the same place and we solve it for
let's look at the results that we saw so
um I have a data frame I just called you
know notice.inset that gives me how many
documents inserting is pretty fast it's
just Computing the embeddings that are
pretty slow
um we'll talk about this piece about the
different types of indexes in the next
section
yep so
um
there are like some parameters that you
can pass when you create again you'll
talk about this in the next section when
you specifically talk about type index
but once you have your database you know
using the python client for millbus you
just give it a vector you tell it which
field or a rich embedding field you want
to search for which Fields you want to
do so the API is very clean
um one thing I want to highlight here is
that you see here it took about 206
milliseconds you see remember in the
elasticsearch notebook it took about
final seconds so this is pretty
expensive operation compared to like the
bm35
but let's look at you know for this
performance recognition are we getting
good results
so
so this is equation and results we get
for you know two dogs playing with snow
um you see in the description so here we
are embedding the description field
right so we embedding brown and black
thought s it's going to spill I think
this result is pretty good you know it's
understanding running and playing kind
of matters in the same space
result looks pretty relevant to me
I'm kind of thing I'm still picking up
two dogs like this is a very small
purpose so
um the results may not be the best
um if you remember this very when we
looked at bm35 which is not the best but
if you look the way from boy to go on
the beach you know like children it kind
of matched
um
yeah match that way and to this
description so I would say it's doing a
pretty good job definitely better much
better compared to the M25 approach that
we looked at and maybe let's look at the
final kind of hashtags and for example
you know light at the end of the tunnel
um you know again the description is
just like like people
um my direction I would say like these
things at least for me are more relevant
than what we saw in the theater yes uh
so this YouTuber is based on the
description
um
for all the
photos and yes yeah so
um I do talk about this a little bit
later but the general idea is like when
you do a retrieval it's not sometimes
just enough for like
um Vector similarity sometimes you might
want to see like I want photos that I
similar but you know my arm is the
license is open source or something or
like it has at least 1000 views or
something so you need your vector
database to be able to support those
things
um but that's a great question yeah
yeah um
yeah I mean this is the side there was a
lot have been covered with
um embedding and embedding based
retrieval but I just hope if you're very
able to follow along with this notebook
to show that how easy it is to kind of
get started with an existing embedding
how easy it is easy to use like an open
source or academics like nervous and use
the python find insert and find
yourselves
is there any way you can do this
embedding elasticsearch
yeah that's a good um thing because
since elasticsearch in its most recent
version it does support our Vector
database I think like version 9.2 or
um so you can use it so it is what it is
yes so the middle of this is like a
database
Architects already
is that right uh I mean um here we
embedded like a description so so uh we
we inserted metadata and we inserted
embeddings for text but you could have
inserted like image embedding or like
some joint embedding
um
right but I mean is it I guess
but I mean is it is it already uh
of
catalog a phone website
metadata
oh yes I just came over that field a
little bit typically so that 25
um photo collection that we saw like
um I did create the
embedding from the model so
um yeah so now I mean face Dan said I
just called model.in code with this
model and
the insert the embedding of the
descriptions
but this embedding could be like the
word comparing that we saw before or
like image to back or less to back
um
so
um yes yeah so
those your process or yeah so I guess
your processed capable of leveraging
embedding space actually uh index the
vector
database so that you can accelerate
Retreat all depending on whichever
kernel you'd like to reference between
the similarity of the vectors
[Music]
thanks uh so um do you know how like
when you have an embedding space And
depending on like whichever like um when
I'm you are comparing sentence first
um you're generally going to have like
some form of any
inner product that's passive in this
case it's going to be cosine
um is there any way that you can
actually like index or Shard or search
based off of like how close they would
relate to each one of those so that you
can retrieve the information faster or
maybe like you can have reverse intent
so being able to like more so say oh hey
what if I went to find something that's
not this uh would that be a built-in
feature if that Vector sort so uh in the
next section we'll talk about like
buildings and like directly database to
make it possible to the table like
behind the shotting and stuff but
the similar thing is not really easy
problems yeah that's not quite there
um yeah that's a great question
um
so
yeah I think I'll let my focus Center
Robbie tickets from here
um yeah
uh before we go into the next section do
we have any top any issues for the
removal software
yeah
okay
so hi my name is
so so far I think what they've looked at
is
what are the issues of bm35
and if we go to the embedding based on
Project how can we find out similar text
right we have something we have a
purpose we have all the problems
something to start using embeddings just
based on text
so before we go to the different use
cases of that there's one thing that I
um multiple color
so
one thing I'm going to cover was how do
you train your marks so you're given
nearest neighbor search and you know
your trip or you'd like to change your
embeddings but one of the main issue
that happens when you're training your
models we are wearing is what kind of
data are you using so it's very easy to
have positive sounds you know what is
similar to what and the question that
you have like how do you find the system
like this so it's not always easy to
find the similarities but you still
start with something which you know that
apple is not similar to Orange you know
in a context but it could be but it's
still not similar so we call them
negatives right so it's very easy to
have positives you can still start with
some negative but how do you generate
more negatives as you go along so this
is a concept that was there in online
learning you're still there which is
called as hard negatives
so
basically this is what we call it an
easy learning so you have the anchor is
the query that you're searching for and
here are positive samples on the
negative samples that were there and
what's return as opposed to sample and
it the end up query is similar to the
first example and that's what you're
looking for
now the second case is this where
positive negative samples we need a
report because they are very closer to
each other and the actor in which you
are searching is still very fun like it
says we can still call it like semi-aut
because it's still uh closer to the
positive sample than foreign
so these data points that you're
selecting are these extra queries they
could be called as your hard Networks
hard negatives
so so far what we've seen
researchers you have text workers and
you want to search for something using a
text
but as the e-commerce and other systems
are going you don't really want to
search for text you may want to also
search for vision or image Solutions
so one of the uh
already I can tell that uh recently got
popular because of money yeah
you have embeddings for your text and
you also have embeddings for your images
and you're trying to train them together
for a for a function and if I could
create those embeddings such that the
two embeddings both of them vision and
text they are similar to each other
so that's what uh what happens in flip
but
as you see with other different systems
you don't have to stop with the text and
image you can extend this to our Google
has done for their App Store so you just
search for let's say Facebook app
Windows Voice or something you they want
to connect that to an app right now you
have all these features that you can use
for the query and the app Feature
sometimes even the user features so all
of these things could be could be used
to create two embodies that you see at
the end before the dot product that is
very embedding on the app
and you can train this architecture for
using cross entropy for an optimal
function that you try to optimize so if
you're trying to optimize for these
users
searching for something and they end up
clicking on or downloading those
software those apps then you can use
these to train them and eventually what
you get is delivered
and the applicant you can use these two
Organics to do the nearest data set to
find out if somebody searches for this
and what is the app that is similar to
us
okay so we're gonna have another quick
lab to
basically learn about
the similar kind of experience that
we've been seeing so far do the trade
free searches but we want to go to
predict image let's see you know what
kind of results we get
yes so we will be using uh quick models
the clip model is
trained for finding embeddings of your
images give a text
so I quickly want to show the results
because uh there's something fancy about
it it's something similar to about text
you have a model you put your Corpus
into it and then you train it because in
this case there is a pre-trained with
model so this is the kind of result that
we see that we see when we use the query
uh two dots playing in small I think
this was a similar thing that you were
saying earlier with the next many years
ago so
this is the second one which in this
case we see that friends will be friends
so there's no tax similarity between
what they're searching for but if you
look at the image this is the image that
which is similar to the previous image
so not only it's similar to these kind
of approaches terms of that not only
this is similar to the text that you're
searching for but these two images that
we saw with this one and the previous
one they are also much similar to each
so
and then you know we have this one set
and further down and so and so
and this is another one which is the
search pin that we have is going around
the Heat and you're going to look at
this image and the title of this it just
says white sense has no context about a
boy or the beach or any of those things
but just by looking at the image I'm
learning you can tell that this image
has something which translates or which
is similar to the product user
and I think when we
um
one of the examples that we're looking
for which was
again in the same time it says here that
will happen but I don't know when it was
related to but it still looks like what
you're searching for just from the image
before we go to the next slide is there
any question about uh click model so how
was it using the similarity images or
descriptions
yeah so let's go back to like how we're
doing similarity between 12 minutes so
we have two vectors they could be our
dimension of these and we are trying to
find out the theory of distance between
them but you can do a DOT product or
cosine some varieties other things and
we can we're trying to find out how
close are these two embedics are
and the pros that they have so you'll
get a start between them they are
similar
and the reason why we are sure about it
because in the frame when you're
training these are batteries we get the
type of the other five importance
they were trying we were training them
the players that these are similar for
these artists the positive samples
so let's put more into uh you know the
question that I was basically asked what
was how are we doing and what exactly is
happening here how are we searching for
something so we can we can think of all
these uh Dots here as our Corpus our
search space all the vectors that we
have that we have generated with the
image vector or the the text vectors so
we have this 3D or visual space and then
the one highlighted is our event
and the the basic idea would be try to
find out distance from this Vector to
all the vectors in the space and see
which one is the process
so that's what we call it as flat index
we type such
for this Vector against all the vectors
right
and the issue with this factor is of
this this approach is it's not optimal
because it runs at the order of end
because you have to compute it with all
the uh data points if you have
so the other solution or the optimum the
optimization that you would build on top
of it which was the previous question
can we do something about it rather than
searching for everything can we do
something meaningful about that so one
of the approach is uh can we do an
involved in uh inverted index and that
would be this sort of looking so this is
our problems right we haven't started
but this is our purpose and
we see that there are certain clusters
all over the place right so the idea is
instead of if I know that this cluster
has a property and this is over here and
this cluster is over here and if a new
item comes in and it tells that this is
that new uh query is similar to this
cluster but too far from this cluster
can I use some of these learnings to
only look into this question right so to
do that we have to first create uh how
to say a data structure which tries to
find out the centroids of all of these
data points so all of these clusters so
this cluster perhaps entered here and
this one over here and and so on and so
forth and then
once we do that
this is the kind of uh
architecture or data structure that we
get we are not eliminating their sources
they are still there but we're just
adding another layer which says that on
these drugs these are the on this data
source this is these are the central
terms so we're not optimizing more of
the memory but we will be optimizing all
the reply
and how that happens is this so this is
our
Source tree or the data period that we
are searching for and what we do is we
find out the distance from this uh query
to let's say all the centroids and it
tells us that this is closer to these uh
so and then you can also do for one we
could probably find out the simple one
how do we so there are certain features
of collide system and properties or
parameters that are used when we search
for these kind of solutions one of them
is pro there is one that I missed is
called as enlist
so in this so endless tells us how many
centroids do we want so if you have n
elements if you want to have n centroids
we are basically just building this flag
but if you want if you want to reduce uh
and uh and endless from hand to a
smaller number we are trying to reduce
it we are trying to create more uh what
currency smaller clusters
a few number of systems
and with that we can also determine how
many uh clusters to prompt when we are
looking for
so again if we both are end then we are
basically using the platforms
so most of the indexes that are built it
can be categorized into three basic
projects one of them is the tree the one
that we looked at earlier the other one
is hashes where you can hash certain
things you know similar to the
dictionaries and the other one is graph
so
this is one of the uh
I would say index that is used these
days mostly all these search systems for
all the various Network systems okay and
this is a graph case so what it does
instead of having all the trees or all
the their points thrown around it tries
to find out uh all the all the
common items in each layer and then it
has one entry point from this layer to
the next time so it's kind of like a
skip list approach that's there in the
gas structures where you each layer
tells that I I can go and if you can go
to the next one it skips all the
elements because
so it's something similar that this
argument has
say copied from the scripted
where it tells you how quickly you can
go and find it so if you trace this path
of the of the query vector
uh every graph or every uh index will
have an entry point this is where you
have to go in and then you try to find
out the layers from this layer and then
you go further down because this has a
connection here and then you find a
nearest one here and then you go down
and then you find the latest from here
so this is a similar to traversing
through a tree but it's exactly
uh any questions here
so these are some of the benchmarks that
we can talk about so as we were talking
about the inverted index
when we were creating the Clusters we
saw that if you have uh if you have n
data points and you create n number of
clusters and you want to search for all
the end clusters basically
doing the flat index which means you are
saying I want the equal of one because
nothing can be better than that
so if you look at this line what we can
see here is that as your props increase
you are you're increasing your brick
wall but then you are reducing the
number of queries that you can process
per second
because it's going to be much much
smaller and this is going to be like a
flat indexer on the blue line uh so
that's that's all it is but the
advantage that we see with uh
the hierarchical
navigable
it's not for a small ones so what you
see there is though we have created out
a bigger Arrow structure there because
you know we have graphs and layers and
your crafts to them the advantage that
you see with them is when you are
looking for a larger they are set to
servers and you are looking for the
recall of one so what we see here is
that not only at the lower uh recall
they can process we process multiple
queries but if you're looking for very
high recall this approach is very
similar very close to the group forces
so if you're if you're a little bit
relaxed in terms of the recall that
you're looking for you can use the uh
this layer and this layer performs much
better for the fractions
and so the recall is how many
um so record of one would be are you
looking for two dogs playing in snow and
you have something which has two dots
plugins now let's say you you're looking
for all the text that has two logs
plugins
and introduce you everything but if
either equal is less then it means
sometimes it may throw you uh logs
playing
just because if you look at the uh the
centroid that we created here so it's
possible that when you are probing it
you might be probing this one and get
your result but you could have
if you you could have been nearer to the
centroid to the point here in this
cluster but you could probably get one
from this there's a cluster was closed
so basically how many clusters you need
to scan yes so if you're like if you
limit your clusters you are basically
giving up on the uh on the recall on the
equality
is the number of items that you want
return which should be the one that you
want them to write yeah
so are you maximizing recalls so that
you can address Precision at the
classification layer or does this
address both of them
in terms of ranking yeah
uh are you trying to maximize recall
here so that later Downstream you can
address Precision or either be addressed
oh you know this is basically that this
one is
uh the recall of each model itself so
it's not about each layer oh okay okay
yeah this is already you know the whole
design itself okay so basically uh
you you're looking for some stuff in
many systems you know sometimes speed
could be more of your interest than the
actual vehicle you may want some good
result to be out there but not exactly
wait for the perfect result to be found
so that's why a number of queries that
you can process per second could be of
interest to you than the actual result
so if I'm searching for uh let's say
honest on Google app section for the
nearest restaurant to me and there are
two restaurants which are like equal
distance from my place and if it gives
me one this will give me both I would
still be okay with it so that way I
would want a system where I want the
queries that can be processed faster but
the other thing could be if I'm looking
for a hospital and there's a hospital
which is like closer to me and instead
of just it gives me a lot of problems a
little bit away from me maybe even like
100 meters I would want it to be better
on the position and you know maybe get
that result
Ed so it depends on what you're
optimizing
this
is
the political images
up so in order to index is built purely
on the embedding stage
so just based on the embeddings you're
trying to create our clusters
ignoring the uh the label that you have
the full purpose full course yeah so you
basically start with uh
to start with everything that you have
and then you try to find out the
sentence
all right
so um
they're a lot of I would say any options
that are out there we in our practice
have used fires and bills so these
libraries or these packages
they can help you put your direct data
into them your embarrassing them and
they also help you find some of these
uh you know have they also support like
multiple indexes some other map all the
indexes that you're looking for somebody
they don't have those that you are
interested in some could be specifically
what are the parameters that we use to
identify which one do you want to use so
what is the management or samples all
these you can close to your online
desktop or laptop or whatever you want
to the second one parameter would be
performance which system gives you
better performance or even Hardware or
at a given week or decisionability
the third one is very important uh it
really goes back to your use case which
is how frequently do you think your
purpose is going to change
so if you have a system where you're in
the same exercise system something let's
say for Instagram and they want to keep
on updating those images then maybe a
particular solution could be of interest
where it is also possible that you have
documents that you have already that you
know that they're not going to change as
frequently so you can use the other
system so there are some systems or some
indexes that are good for creating one
sometime and then you can you can create
them as much as
so those are three important ones and
then we also have sometimes uh
conditions that you want all the items
that are similar to this Vector but you
also want them to have some secondary uh
criteria in it so for example if I'm
looking for the image that we had which
is show me all the images where uh
invested is now but it should be there
right so you're looking for so so
because you're adding that condition
there so you're looking for all the
images and then you want to add a layer
of filtering there so some systems May
support it sometimes Some solid systems
may not support
so that's
and press two I would say they are most
most the last one is because on the
plugins some have some plugins that you
want to use some may not have those
things
so this is the concept of filtering that
we were talking about so
what we were talking about earlier was
you can you have all these data points
in your cluster right now let's say you
have a flat index just to explain it and
then we are looking for something we
have a query Vector in this case let's
say this red one is a player and we are
saying give me the processed n number of
candidates but they should meet a
certain criteria and that criteria is
not called foreign
[Music]
sometimes the reason why it can be uh of
importance is how many data points that
it should read to apply this winter
all the strategy could be or the rules
force would be read everything that
that's out there and then talk about the
filter which is not optimal and the
other one could be just read only 10 and
then expand you know next 10 and next
time and next time so some systems are
optimized just for applying filters so
most of the e-commerce you have those uh
cases where you're via aquarium above on
top of the query you're saying okay I'm
looking for something like this but if
you have these conditions as well
something that can be shipped faster or
something that is below this dollar and
something like that so these criterias
can become important when you have
systems
not just about
okay oh does it apply that filter before
yes so it tries to First find out the
candidates for you and then apply it
all right I'm not sure if there's a
system that does the other way because
you first won't find out your neighbors
or your candidates that these are closer
to this query and then you want to apply
the filter on top of it because you are
saying I'm looking for images or apps or
search items which are similar to this
but then on top of that iPhone just
conditioned
right so I will say that uh what I would
expect that the variety of
query match should be higher than the
American Airlines
yeah and this is I think what we were
discussing earlier that you can do
hydrating fuels full retrievals so
elasticsearch supports uh well you know
narcissism
uh support both of these
okay
[Music]
so what are we going to do in this lab
is we will build an an index
using all these libraries and then we'll
try to do a search on that on that index
so the notebook that we're using is
a
fourth notebook
all right
okay
so yeah I think at this point uh if you
want to open the notebook and you want
to go through it and try you know some
of these songs because all these are
like basic which is we have a lot of
these libraries and I for this
particular example we're using fire
slavery suffice is a library from
Facebook uh where this is basically our
latest Device search system search
search Library where you can put in your
index
while you're putting your index you have
an option to decide if you have an
option that you want to use the CPU to
build that index I want business between
CPU or you want to just use GPU the
issues with the gpus is if your index is
too large cannot fit in your GPU Ram
then you may want to use the CPU but the
advantage is uh in our experience
it can be a magnitude faster to have
your windows on GPU and search engine
then having a indexing CPU
foreign
[Music]
I think it's always true for this but I
think you can train your indexes
so that's what it says so when you are
putting your data in it you have an
option of training it and if you add
more data to it you have options
so basically uh those imported indexes
that we were talking about so for flat
index you don't have a critical refining
because it's probably flat but if you're
using any other index like inverted
index you put your data to it it's going
to create those centroids and then you
have more datability okay you want to
train it so that it creates from those
androids
yeah
so the easy part here is you have
assemblings you just go to the index you
add them and then because
and once we do that we can quickly do
search now what it's going to do with
search is it's gonna it has two elements
one or two I would say an arrays uh one
of them is a distance uh array and the
other one is the item index so the
distance basically tells you how one of
the distance between these uh the query
Vector that you have and the indexes
that it written on it which is things
are similar to your query what is the
distance between them and the reason why
distance can be of importance is
you can have for the rules on it that if
the distance is lesser than this so this
is greater than this and I'm going to
discard my results so in those cases
distance could be something of you know
very important
so in this case what we are doing is we
are written you know we are we're just
testing
so we are just testing here uh if I give
one element to it and I want it to
return k equal to one just one icon
now again it depends on what is the size
of your purpose this one has only 35
000 images in it you can try with like
medium data points as well in your
experience this is still going to be
very efficient
so the second time here is where we are
saying uh search for every element that
is there in the Corpus and give you one
element it basically means we are
searching for ourselves in the index
right so even for that we still feel
that the
time is pretty good
and as I was saying uh D is the distance
vector
the first element has uh this sort of
zero so this is the result of what we
saw earlier which is we are saying take
off these uh
data points and give me the nearest
neighbor for all these data points that
are there in your index which is the
same as the data points that are data in
index which means for every Vector we
should get one vector which is itself
out and the distance for that should be
Z
so essentially I'll just assume that all
of these are very soon very close to
zero some of them are not but yesterday
because that is not exactly completely
trained but this is still I would say
pretty close to here
yeah so any questions so far regarding
how we are very nervous profiles and
what kind of data we are getting from
any any other consoles regarding
I feel now so far
so if not I'm going to move forward this
is the trainable index so again that we
are giving data to it we want fires to
train uh the data point that we have
given and create the idea
so our concentration right so the flat
index doesn't have to train so this has
to be
and if you see here we are saying is
should use
distance pen tools that's the metric
that will be used to find out
so so yes
so what we saw earlier was when we
when we asked fires to give us we became
one item we asked it to return more item
for us and we looked at the time that it
did it was somewhere in the magnitude of
10 milliseconds or so
but now because of this converted index
we see that it has created those
centroids and because of that it's
probably like searching faster so we see
that it has dramatically improved then
we are only saying that look at only one
cluster to get this item
and one thing to remember here is that
this is again on CPU
these systems are optimized to run on
GPS so if you use a GPU you're going to
see
much faster business
foreign
right so four clicks or what is three
but you can see that if the customers
search with this they buy these items
and they search for this and they buy
the same item or you know similar items
so that could be used as a positive uh
you know confused positives
so that could basically tell us that if
you go like in this particular queries
that people are using they are buying
similar products then maybe the queries
will be the same
so you can use those kind of uh I would
say information when you're training
your parents
good question just wanted to know your
take when you have vocabulary Gap
instead of Mexico Gap let's say you can
search for fancy clothes or fancy toys
do you have any any ideas on how to
handle vocabulary
yes so if something is not part of your
uh
vocabulary and you know how it organizes
gonna handle that so one of the I think
I think at this side was if you don't
have it you can train them
right so different systems have
different ways of handling Auto
vocabulary
cases some I put them as a default 4.5
use that but at some point you decide if
you want to train your vocabulous
organizers or you want to keep on using
them so it depends on how many out of
tokens you are how many calories
the context of e-commerce
um how can you boost queries based on
like
information around
you know
patients
so
let's go back to
the slide here
so basically let's say we have a we have
a pretty good
and then what you're saying is
our location features so depending on
pass
depending on whatever information you
want to include
[Music]
to have all those options
so like in this case what we're doing is
we're trying to create app embedding and
user aquarium but if you just want to
find out the latest queries
[Music]
yeah so the interest of time I will pass
it over to listen again to help us with
the conclusion
foreign
[Music]
retrieval sources so you don't just need
to use
but another example from Instagram
and you know we talk about retrieval but
there could be multiple levels of
retrievals so in this example that they
talked about where they have three
levels of retrieval you know first level
gets from one billion uh posts all the
way to 500 candidates and then the
standard model that you know
uh
drinks the 500 calories so 50 candidates
and then another model
so you can have multiple levels of
retrieval and ranking
and an example from how about where
again they have multiple
multiple sources in retrieval you know I
the game 25 collaborative based model
and many based models and then we have
several levels of ranking
and one small thing
say the order that is given to the
ranking score you know
ordered them in a certain position
[Music]
and in general this is a nice diagram
from from a developer from Nvidia where
you know when you think of building like
the sub system you know there's
retrieval filtering scoring and ordering
and also you need to think about the
online component report
so maybe just one example of how these
things might play for like an e-commerce
scenario like if you're trying to like
uh you know item page try to show like
items that have been purchased together
a little retrieval layer is you know you
have to find items that are similar but
in the filtering layer you know maybe
some items are out of stock so you can't
really you can't really capture that
kind of information in your embedding
database
and then you know the scoring
um maybe their items that are similar
but you might want to store them and
display them based on that specific user
might interact with an item and then you
know from the UI perspective
um even if an item is similar maybe you
want to show like items kind of break
the items based on like like certain
price points
[Music]
um also like you know maybe in a search
system you want to treat like
queries that are like halfway so you
know like long tail queries differently
you might only use your embedding system
like field Trace
kind of deals with the artist
s article tab a little bit better
um the other thing to just you know
Canada it's not like an either or you
know one of course you can use is you
can use like the Deep learning model uh
the doctor so you can basically enhance
your existing documents
runtime
uh you're using like an attacking based
approach to kind of enhance the document
and these extra tokens so hopefully you
know like build any Gap in the document
and um there was a nice Benchmark that
was done so you know there's a lot of
emphasis on like embedding based
retrieval so here we have like our game
25 we have our embedding based model you
know if you look at
there's a several questions about out of
the main vocabulary rights so if you
have a model that is in a smartphone and
then you know you search for car and you
give it you see that landing page is
doing really well compared to
um compared to the dispute bm35 coach
but what happens if you use the
embedding based approach that restraint
and smarter and then you search for like
Google or like tweets it is definitely
going to be uh out of vocab problem
there so it performs much worse than
it's a pure game 25 approach
so
um definitely it might make sense to
kind of use that
previous slide to talk about expanding
the document or like using bm35 and I
think like a possible for a deep
learning model together we see like
together
they perform well together
um one thing just to consider the
production mindset like you saw like how
fast am 25 was the index documents and
the retrained documents
um in the Deep learning models we see
like on a CPU
increasing by a factor of 10. on the GPU
okay maybe it might be it might be
from there
um and like they can find Crossing coded
that was the last column that we saw in
previous table it has the best results
but you know waiting six seconds for a
single query might not make sense we're
useless
um yeah and that's you know if you want
to just read up more on these materials
here are some resources that these are
helpful if um
all the slides are in the GitHub version
so it has
two pages
producer again
thank you
um yeah so all the notebooks are here
the different of environment will still
be online for like this week and then
over the weekend
you know feel free to guidance
environments
um
search
anyway
if you want to play with them
then you can use this little
um there is uh
Docker environment that ends that some
of those dependencies but just kind of
playing around with it the
density Cleaver and the screen print
five it has no experience
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]